هل استولى صدام حسين مختبئا وراء شيء ما
هناك على البلاد ودمرها في الحقيقه كان
مجرد خاسر هذا كل شيء تماما مثل بوتين من
هو الخاص
[موسيقى]
انه يقاتل من اجل حياته هذا ما يقاتل من
اجله اثناء قتاله في اوكرانيا يقاتل بوتين
فقط
لانقاذ حياته انه لا يقاتل حتى من اجل
روسيا ولا من اجل لغته الروسيه انه لا
يقاتل من اجل ذلك ليس من اجل كنيسته انه
يقاتل فقط من اجل حياتك
[موسيقى]
روسيا لن تتوقف في اوكرانيا او روسيا
ستتوقف على وجه التحديد عن طريق اوكرانيا
نحن نقدر الخيار الثاني بانه ليس لدينا
خيار لا نريد ان نكون ضحايا لكن ليس لدينا
خيار سنقاتل حتى النهايه
[موسيقى]
لقد حررنا بعض اراضينا البلد متحد وعلى
فكره البلد متحد من اجل النصر نامل ونصدق
انه بخطوات يوميه نقترب من النصر وانا
واثق من ذلك وهذا مهم جدا هو دافعنا رئيسي
تحرير واستعاده ارضنا